comment mais comment dormir
impossible la nuit qui a suivi de dormir
toujours dans la tête ce sondage idiot
ma nullité pendant l'interview et je
repensais à toutes les fois où je me
voyais chef de tribu ou président to
business woman quand j'étais petit
toujours la place des garçons quand on
voulait me donner le rôle de la fille
bien sage et les colère parce que je ne
voulais pas et les coups de pied dans
les tibias pour me venger et tout ce qui
faisait que je passais pour une petite
peste juste parce que j'avais de
l'ambition la cour de récréation est un
champ de bataille où la loi du plus fort
est la seule règle sauf si un idiot de
ce1 va capter que moi la grande cm2 je
lui ai jeté du sable dans les yeux et
que maintenant cette chaude chouine
parce que c'est lui brûle bref je
repensais à toutes ces injustices
scolaire et je me disais que c'est fou
quand même que des gens qui me voient
jouer dans un soap puisse penser que je
pourrais diriger tout un pays mais
sûrement c'est laura de la star du petit
écran que je suis en train de devenir
alors comme un moyen de dormir
j'ai allumé la télé et là j'ai vu
l'ampleur du désastre
c'est marrant comme jamais j'allume
cette télé alors que j'y suis une star
et je me rends compte que la plupart des
programmes sont d'une stupidité sans nom
les débats politiques on dirait des
classes de maternelle les émissions
dites de divertissement sont insultantes
pour l'espèce humaine
ils ne savent plus quoi inventer comme
jeu pour nous faire gagner du fric et je
ne parle même pas de la publicité le
désespoir m'a pris d'une part parce que
tout ce qui passait dans cette boîte
était terrible mais d'autre part parce
que je me faisais moi-même peur de
penser que cette chose si présente dans
la vie des gens étaient si stupides
comme si je me hissait au dessus de la
populace non mais je me prends pour qui
et avec tout ça pas moyen de dormir
encore plus
questionné gt et si moi j'étais assez
clairvoyante pour changer tout cela
les gens me voyaient bien alors pourquoi
moi je ne me verrais pas et je repensais
à tous les moments où j'avais deviné
juste tous les moments où je savais que
la vieille dame allait tomber sur le
trottoir ou qu'il ne fallait pas manger
ce carpaccio de saumon sous peine de
vomissements ou que cette intervention
militaire ferait mourir des soldats et
ne règlerait aucun conflit est ce que
vous croyez qu'il est possible d'avoir
un don de divination qu'il est possible
de savoir tout avant tout le monde et
particulièrement ceux qui fait mal
est-ce que vous pensez que moi theodora
la petite comédienne de soap je pourrais
devenir la guide de tout un peuple en
évitant les malheurs que je sentirais
que je pourrai ainsi y apporter des
solutions concrètes qui nous sortirait
du chômage et du désespoir
je pensais à tout ça et je suis tombé
sur une rediffusion de trust corp
et là le choc
s'il ya un dieu qu'il me fasse un signe
s'il y a une justice alors expliquez moi
ce que je paye
s'il y a un sens sur cette [ __ ] de
planète
alors quel est il je me suis vu à
l'écran jamais j'avais regardé toujours
j'avais refusé
et là c'était horrible je jouais
tellement mal tout été affectés tout
était convenu et tout était nul
je me suis rêver depuis tout petit
dans ce genre d'émission comme une
déesse parmi les olympiens et maintenant
que j'y suis je constate que les
olympiens jouent comme des brel je me
suis effondrée une fontaine vous voyez
des larmes à n'en plus finir pour
purifier mon corps mon coeur et mon âme
insulté par la médiocrité de ma
prestation et de celle de mes camarades
jamais j'avais voulu voir un seul
épisode on n'aime pas se voir mais à ce
point mauvaise je l'aurais pas cru
comment moi si instinctive
j'avais pu me fourvoyer à ce point est
rien à faire que des hordes de ménagères
et de retraités module rien à faire
qu'on me regarde avec des étoiles dans
les prunelles je devine peut-être pour
les autres les malheurs de leur vie mais
pour moi je suis nul
nous sommes un labyrinthe pour
nous-mêmes m'a dit un jour tu es au
inspiré qu'il était ce jour-là [ __ ]
de labyrinthes mon coeur saignait et je
ne voyais aucune solution pour me sauver
quitter cette série minable et me
présenter aux élections présidentielles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]